the health secretary matt hancock joins
us once again on the program mr hancock
as always good to see you um
good morning good morning to you a year
on
um from the first lockdown a day of
reflection i wonder how you'll be
spending it
well i'll be uh i'll be working mostly
i'll be working on the vaccine rollout
and trying to get us out of this
and that's the that's what i spend all
my waking hours
on at the moment i thought that was a
very moving uh
a very moving package that you've just
shown
and i think a lot of people will be will
be feeling
the same as the emotions expressed in it
both by
his royal highness the prince charles
and also by
the members of the public explaining
that this has been an incredibly
difficult year
and probably the hardest year in a
generation
and yet we all search for hope as well
don't we
and the the hope is that we now
have a root out of this and that root is
possible because of the
the wonders of science and the scale of
the vaccination program
the wonders of science is a very good
way of putting it but on the
the vaccination route out of this
reports this morning
that the government that you in fact and
the prime minister have agreed to a
change in the law
that would compel people working in in
care homes to have a vaccine is that
accurate
well no decisions have been taken as you
know we have a
a task force looking at the question of
certification of whether there's things
that you need to be able to show that
you've had a vaccine or indeed a test
in order to be able to do um that
looks both at the quite these questions
around international travel but is also
looking at the question of whether
in order to be able to care for people
professionally
then you ought to have protected
yourself so that you can't
infect others this is something that
happens already
for instance doctors have to have the
hepatitis b
vaccine and it's clearly something that
has
uh important moral questions on on both
sides so it is something that we're
looking at but it
but no decisions have yet been taken
important moral questions and important
legal questions as well i mean
you would presumably expect a decision
such as this
to be challenged in the court so on that
basis would you
are you currently looking at vaccination
not simply of those who work in care
homes but perhaps
mandatory vaccination for as you put up
just a moment ago people working
in care people caring which could
generally apply to quite a lot of people
in the health service as well
well as i say this already is the case
in terms of hepatitis b
in the nhs for doctors um and
so there is a clear precedent for
this proposition at the moment what
we're looking at is
for those who work in care homes
elderly care homes on the grounds that
they are the most vulnerable to this
disease that's why they were in
the very first cohort of the groups to
be vaccinated
and it is a and it's something that some
care homes have actually called for
because it would require a change in the
law through secondary legislation
and and therefore i entirely understand
why
why some care homes wanting to take that
duty of care
over those who are who are in that home
of the
for the residents um are are keen for us
to be able to take this step
um to so that so that they can uh
require uh people who who could
otherwise pass on the virus to
to take the vaccine there is of course a
fairly big question that follows all of
this that if we are actively considering
mandatory vaccination if you want to
work in a care setting
could we consider mandatory vaccination
more generally
in the public in the population at large
i mean the jcvi
um modeling showed us i think it was in
the tail end of the tail end of last
week the ideal percentage targets for
vaccination
and we're looking at 75 coverage in in
under 50s when we get to that stage that
is a big
target now if we're not coming close to
that target are there circumstances in
which
you could see mandatory vaccination for
people under the age of 50.
no we've ruled that out for the general
population and there's a difference
which is if you you know if you as a
profession care for people and are
therefore in very close contact with
them
then that is that is different to the
the general population
um and um you know on these percentages
they are important
the the uptake amongst the
groups that we're vaccinating is
unbelievably high
over 95 percent now uh in
the most elderly groups
and for care home workers where it is a
bit lower it is now
greater than three quarters uh in
elderly care homes
amongst staff who've been vaccinated
amongst residents is over ninety percent
so these taker rates are really
interrupted sorry we've got so much to
get through and i think the point in
terms of vaccination and care homes has
been made
but there will be people looking at the
the the rate of progress
that we are making in terms of
vaccinations and wondering why the
government is bringing forward
you know fines of 5 000 pounds for
people
who head abroad without good excuse i
mean it does seem
that the government this morning is
basically saying look until
the very earliest july summer is
cancelled
if you're looking to go abroad at the
very least
no i think it's quite important to clear
this one up um
the the the questions of whether people
will be able to
travel abroad this summer are going to
be
addressed by the global travel task
force which is reporting around
the 12th of april so middle of next
month
um the road map sets out that the
earliest date by which
we will um allow for international
travel without
one of the clear excuses
reasons that you need now um is the 17th
of may that has not
changed the way we're putting that into
law is as part of these roadmap
regulations that we voted on on thursday
and they come to an end as a whole at
the
end of june but that doesn't change the
timings for these questions on
international travel
now having said all of that it is now
too early
to know where that the global travel
task force will come out
and know what the decision will be for
the 17th
of may and the reason for that is that
we are
seeing this third wave rising in some
parts of
europe and we're also seeing uh new
variants
and it is very important that we protect
the progress that we've been able to
make
uh here in the uk where we have we have
now in the prime minister yesterday i
mean he was talking about a third wave
you know
developing in europe and and washing up
on our shores when a wave hits our
european friends he said you know
it ends up in our shores it seems a
slightly strange way of talking about
it given that this third wave if you
want to call it that in europe emerged
you know
not far from where i'm standing in kent
we exported it
to the european union well it shows what
an international challenge this
this is and what we have to do
is all work as much as we can together
but it also shows why we're being
cautious on international travel because
know we've seen that that these waves
come
before we saw you know the first and
then the second
and they both ended up here
the the action that you took most
recently on our borders was
in your own words to prevent new
variants from arriving here to prevent
cases coming to the united kingdom why
should we be worried in any way
about a third wave happening on the
continent giving the changes that you've
made
well we should be concerned because we
have seen the impact before
and the the question that your system
we did absolutely but there's also we
also have a
um a desire if if possible if it's safe
to do so to open up
international travel of course people
want i understand people want a
summer holiday abroad if it's safe and
we've got to make that decision on on
whether it's safe and we'll do that
according to the timetable that's set
out in the roadmap
now the the the good news is
that thankfully we have this uh very
significant vaccine rollout here
we've got we you know we've yesterday we
we saw the
30 millionth vaccine overall
both first and second doses combined and
and this this vaccine program is clearly
saving lives here but we need to make
sure that
that we protect that rollout from the
concerns that might come from new
variants and we need to
work on understanding more about
minister minister if if you want to
if you're if you're wanting to take
credit for the vaccination program and i
i understand when you do then you have
to
at some point accept some of the
criticism that is laid at the door we
are a year on
from the first lockdown and according to
the johns hopkins tracking
we are fifth in total deaths sixth in
deaths
per hundred thousand sixth and deaths
per population
why has that happened why in terms of
mortality
compared to other countries have we done
so poorly
well the that's a very important
question and it's one that
it'll be the right time to assess that
in the future
but now the right task is to
spend all of our energies on so can you
explain this virus
might be on its way here when is the
appropriate time
you know if things go badly we could
still be in this
same time next year if things go
catastrophically we could still be in
this in some form
at which point you could again say look
we're still in the middle of it we're
still dealing with it
you've been in charge of our pandemic
response you personally
must have an idea why we are sixth in
the world
in deaths uh per capita
well i think that i i think the point
that you make is an important one
because
um it's trying to get this country
out of this pandemic that is what i
spend all of my time on
and vital and central to that task
is constantly to learn about what has
worked well
and what we need to do better and
differently and we've done that
presumably would be an independent
inquiry i'm not going to waste your time
on mine
by asking for you to to promise that one
will be set up straight away
but perhaps on today of all days you
could promise you could reiterate in
fact the promise that the prime minister
made in july of last year
that there will be a full inquiry as
soon as possible yes i i think it's
of course the prime minister set out
that there needs to be
all of these questions and i think
that's totally reasonable not least
because we need
permanently in future permanently to be
ready for
another pandemic um that is a
that is a fact of life and it's
something that we need to be
uh prepared for and we need to make sure
that all of the
learnings and all of the scientific
improvements we've been talking about
uh are are understood and that we
are properly ready but
the um but you know what we need to do
right now is learn those lessons in
practice
to make sure that the actions that we
take now
are guided by our best understanding of
this virus
and our best understanding of the of the
pandemic and we've done that throughout
um and um you know that has led to
um the the road map with its cautious
but i very much hope irreversible uh
timetable
and and you know we get people saying
can't you go faster and
can't you open up international travel
you know more easily
and uh and also some people saying can't
you go slower but i think the va
you know the general bulk of the
population most people
think that this is at about the right
pace
and the scientists the best science
thinks that this is at about the right
place but we'll keep monitoring the data
to make sure that it's safe to take each
step and that you know that's at the
uh the core that builds on learning you
know as much as we can
and trying to make the very best
judgments in what are very
difficult circumstances yeah they are
they are they are very
they are very difficult circumstances
indeed we do need to let you go minister
very conscious of the time uh that you
need to spend with other interviews this
morning so thanks very much for being
with us
thanks for having me on